what's going on guys this is rob and i
know the obi-wan kenobi videos we make
are not the most popular i don't care i
like i just i love talking about it
here's the thing i loved episode five
specifically i loved the whole fight
between riva and darth vader that was
probably if i'm being honest i think
that's one of the greatest lightsaber
fights or like just duels that i've seen
in star wars and i know it goes against
conventional wisdom and i'll explain why
here in a minute but one of the things
that i really loved about the whole
episode was that it kind of humanized
everybody right it sort of brought
everybody down that up to this point
it's largely just been these characters
that have been thrown into the show for
varying reasons and we didn't really
know anything about their stories a
really good example of this is the
character of tala right like we didn't
really know her story i mean she was
just kind of there and we knew that she
worked for the empire at one point then
defected to what i guess you could call
the rebel alliance i don't know if it's
really the rebel alliance at this point
and it's just kind of been working
against the empire ever since but we
didn't know her story one of the cool
things about this that i loved about her
telling that story about how they were
basically just there to round up people
as far as they were aware as far as they
had been told because they weren't
paying taxes different things like that
when in reality they were on a mission
to round up force sensitives and then
hand them over to the inquisitors i love
that because one of the things that it
does is it kind of changes the way that
you see
members of the empire right like
officers foot soldiers essentially
anybody but like darth vader the emperor
and probably stormtroopers right that
the funny thing about this is when you
look at them historically from like the
movie perspective or even some of the tv
shows they just kind of look like people
who are there right and it's like okay
whatever they're just officers more
often than not unless you're talking
about like admiral piet or somebody like
that who's of particular importance in
the movies they're just people who are
there and do things and you almost kind
of dismiss them right you almost just
kind of like i mean you know whatever
and you assume that for whatever reason
they just hold this wholesale allegiance
to the empire but i never really looked
at it from the perspective of like they
were quote unquote just following orders
which is an interesting road to take
right it's an interesting approach to
take that being said it also does make
perfect sense that imperial officers and
people like that are basically being
sent on missions and not being told what
those missions actually are and the
reason why i think that's so cool and so
important is because it really kind of
shows for those officers they're still
just regular individuals with their own
moral compass and for whatever reason
they joined the empire right for
whatever reason they they joined that
cause maybe they believed that they were
doing the right thing but when you tell
them we're sending you on a mission to
round up families including kids and
we're just going to get rid of them all
a lot of folks will probably say no to
that
so being duped right being tricked and
then being told like that's the whole
thing now she's only one person and her
story doesn't seem to indicate that
anybody else any of anybody that was
with her turn coded against the empire
and it just kind of worked here the
whole story is from her perspective but
i loved that whole thing and i loved
that whole thing because it kind of
brought her back down to a more human
level and by extension presumably and
possibly a lot of the other officers
that exist out there that work for the
empire as well now of particular
importance in this episode it's one of
the things that i also liked leia
obi-wan kenobi all of them they were
kind of background characters the main
stars of the show were sort of
background characters to a degree there
were three other things that i loved
about this the first thing that i loved
really four other things that i loved
the first thing that i loved was the
whole story about riva right from now on
when it comes to theories i'm just gonna
defect to you guys and be like what do
you guys think's happening you guys are
gonna be like here's what i think is
happening it's like hey guys so you all
came up with great theories and it's
most likely true because a lot of you
guys called it early a lot of you guys
were like i mean reeva is most likely
just a youngling who survived by
whatever manner and whatever means and
that was that was kind of it and it
makes perfect sense right i mean i love
getting lost in theories and i love
coming up with like crazy extravagant
theories to me the simplest answer
usually turns out to be the most boring
one having said that i did think it was
cool the way they did the whole thing
with reba she was basically just a
youngling who survived now i loved how
they pulled the rug out from under that
because as soon as she was telling her
story and she was like i just played
dead my first thought was okay that
doesn't make any sense because surely
anakin skywalker at the height of his
power would be able to if nothing
nothing more use the force to be able to
to discern whether or not these guys are
dead because if also mighty had to do
was just play dead in order to survive
the purge of order 66 a lot of people
would have done that and i'm sure a lot
of people tried that
there'd be a lot more jedi walking
around than there are right now so i was
like there's no way
that that's true i loved how they yanked
the rug out from under that and that in
effect vader knew it the whole time
anakin skywalker knew the entire time
that riva was faking and from the time
that she had presumably faked dead or at
least showed up on the scene and said
you know i want to join the empire until
that moment at the end of the show she
was just being used it was all just some
kind of a ruse now that kind of begs the
question how was it that she was able to
become an inquisitor and demonstrate
force sensitivity and use a lightsaber
at the same time likely she passed
herself off as somebody who had never
had anything to do with the jedi council
or anything and she was just a person
born out there with forced sensitivity
and like that was it right in the same
way that like the empire was rounding up
you know people out there who had force
abilities and most likely turn them to
inquisitors or to dark jedi if they
didn't want to turn they would kill them
that for whatever reason riva just
demonstrated the ability that the empire
decided to keep her right now we know
what was going on behind the scenes is
that vader largely made an exception
because he's like we can use her to
basically track down obi-wan kenobi so i
loved that whole thing the death of the
grand inquisitor and all that just a
great big huge ruse right great big huge
trick i loved that i thought it was
great because what it showed is that
vader's not just some lumbering beast
going on out there which we'll actually
kind of contradict here in a second but
he's not some dim-witted buffoon out
there who's just following the orders of
the emperor and that's it that kind of a
thing it still shows that vader is
incredibly cunning and it shows that
vader's still incredibly intelligent
right that i loved that aspect i loved
that aspect of him when he was anakin
and i love that they maintain that
aspect of him now that he's darth vader
because it's very easy to find yourself
in that position of power that vader has
and then almost kind of rest on your
laurels right and almost just kind of
find yourself losing your grip right
losing that sort of cunning nature
because there's nobody there to
challenge you and so as a result of that
there's no reason to kind of keep those
skills going so i love that whole thing
having said that let's talk about the
fight between darth vader and riva i
love that fight oh my god i love that
fight for a variety of reasons if i'm
being honest with you guys i think it's
one of the best fights that we've seen
darth vader have and here's the reason
why i know it didn't have like all the
extravagant lightsaber maneuvers and
different things along those lines but
that fight was only as good as it was
because we learned the story of riva
this shoe is fighting with vengeance and
anger and different things like that in
the scenes or really the multiple scenes
where you kind of had that little duel
that took place that training session
between obi-wan kenobi and anakin when
anakin was younger when he was still at
padawan it was obi-wan kenobi hitting at
the idea that anakin's still reckless
that anakin still has this quest to
prove himself and until he finds some
measure of inner peace he'll stay a
padawan what this really seemed to
indicate is it seemed to show that
anakin both learned and didn't learn
that obi-wan kenobi was like anakin's
blinded by vengeance all he wants is me
right i'm the only thing that he wants
and he's blind to everything else or
seemingly blind to everything else what
this demonstrated combined with the fact
that anakin knew that riva was uh
youngling the entire time it shows that
he learned like it shows he learned his
lessons with obi-wan kenobi and i loved
that right he was playing the long game
that obi-wan was always trying to teach
him patience so he's like what better
way to demonstrate patience than
literally almost like a decade or so of
time passes and i'm playing this long
game i loved that i love that whole
thing but the fight between riva and
vader right this this this whole thing
was cool because what it showed is that
in a lot of ways riva was now playing
the role of anakin when anakin was the
padawan and anakin as vader is playing
the role of obi-wan when obi-wan was
anakin's master that vader here
demonstrated patience he demonstrated a
lack of recklessness i also thought it
was pretty damn baller that he defeated
this girl without ever having once
popped his lightsaber i love that right
just using the force now here's what i
here's what i thought was really really
cool right this is what i thought was
really really cool there was no
extravagant lightsaber maneuverability
with darth vader even when he did take
riva's lightsaber and take one half of
it and then give her the other half that
she showed finesse right i mean a little
bit of recklessness and she's she's not
polished right her fluids her movements
aren't that fluid and you should have a
little bit of way to go in order to like
master lightsaber dueling right but she
was far more fluid than vader was and i
love that contrast right then when vader
was simply just using the force this
girl never had a chance and it was it
was obvious it was like okay this girl
no i mean vader's literally i don't even
have to pop my lightsaber to beat you
girl like he's just using the force and
moving and moving her out of the way and
dodging her you know blocking her
lightsaber shots let's also talk about
that moment when vader stopped the ship
with the force that was legit
that's what's up i absolutely love that
but uh you know i i love that duel
between the two of them because once he
finally got a lifesaver right once he
took that that half of her lightsaber
and used it for himself he was
cumbersome he was clumsy right it was it
was like i mean has this guy ever lifted
a lightsaber before and i loved that
because he's got this great big huge
bulking suit which slows down his
maneuverability prevents him from being
able to be as agile as he was before he
had the suit when he was in his human
form i loved that contrast because what
it shows is the true power of vader is
in his for in his use of the force and
his cunning nature that his lightsaber
skills that's long gone right he's not
the darth vader he used to be i loved
that i absolutely loved that whole thing
and finally the the thing that i really
love the most here right what i
absolutely loved the most about this
whole episode is that they still kept
darth vader as this kind of menacing
omnipresent force there is such a thing
as overusing vader it's entirely
possible right like it's easy to overuse
darth vader but what i loved right the
thing that was so cool about this is
that darth vader was maintained as this
is kind of menacing dark presence that
when he arrives on the scene it's a big
deal but i also love the idea that while
he did learn his lessons from obi-wan
kenobi in a lot of ways he's still
anakin in a lot of ways he's still
anakin skywalker that he hasn't become
the darth vader that we're the most
familiar with in episodes four and five
and six right just the guy who's slower
the guy who's more methodical he's
getting there but he's not quite there
yet he's still filled with emotion he's
still filled with passion he's still
filled with just this vengeance this
hunger to hunt obi-wan kenobi i mean
when you look at the scene from episode
4 and you compare it to this there's
there's far less emotion there with
darth vader right he's not nearly as
emotional not nearly as reckless he's
far more patient far more methodical
than he is here and i loved that i
absolutely i love that comparison so
what it shows us and the thing that's so
cool about this is it shows us the
evolution of darth vader he's still a
little more anakin than he is
traditional darth vader but he's getting
to that point and i i just i mean this
this was this is obviously the best
episode of the whole show right which
makes the most sense it was just a
phenomenal episode absolutely love it i
thought it was amazing but i'm really
curious to see how things wrap up
because as far as i'm aware we're what
like one episode out from the ending of
the show i'm really excited to see how
the whole thing ends and how this whole
thing concludes but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace